can knock down the three show cuts in
the preseason
and right on cue with the drive and the
nice finish as he scoops it up off the
backboard
there's sga trying to slip by ingles
what a shot
to his driver
[Music]
he's closing out hard they know he can
shoot the three all right we don't we're
not sure what he can do once he get
he catches the ball and puts it on the
floor well that's not in doubt anymore
folks
trying to get the shot off now he's to
slip it over to sga that's the shoot
how about sga just making it look easy
you know he had a couple of those plays
the other night in utah as well
not a notion to go back down low
takes the bump steps back off bonga
beautiful
shot for sga
sga stutter step harder
[Applause]
this is nice here off the left foot he's
a right-handed player
every night i tell you folks he's just
showing you something different
quickly goes right at gordon picks it up
sga
wants to drive and the finish inside
nice move just enough of a hesitation
he's going fast enough he can change
gear down below the free throw line at
nurling noel was able to poke it away
from capella
numbers for the thunder gill just
alexander off the pass and the finish
nicely done
straight poke away getting in transition
here
those are the kind of plays you want to
make against the start at
[Applause]
and continue to knock down shots as you
see right there
trying to play it out without fouling
hard and kick the basketball and the
thunder back on offense shooter finds
sga
open wing three and he splashes it home
with 19.3
seconds left that is just great action
and now paul with the deflection creates
the steal
trying to find a man slashing to the rim
and killed his alexander
takes his time on top of that
hard drive sga down the lane use that
right hand on the left side of the rim
and yet to score over a hundred pass
inside
kick back outside sj goes right by isaac
that's what developing this team sga
what stutter step got that left hand and
he scooped it up and in off the
backboard what a sweet move
time to work with
sj off the bounce stop oklahoma city for
the lone visit on
sunday and then back to back
thunder will return home sga what a
drive what a finish as he went right at
purdle in the lane
can't get it to fall derozan is number
one
in mid-range shots so you can see sort
of sga
get inside a little side step on
aldridge and then aldridge stepped over
the baseline and turns it back over
point guard he was just amazing with the
basketball
[Applause]
sj got caught in the air fortunate the
gallow was in the vicinity
oh the nice snow look behind the back
pass again the defense falls asleep
for the easy slams pretty past vision
looking good
that is beautiful the offense through
adams
trying to get rid of it to somebody out
on the perimeter finally
it's still just alexander who slices and
dices up embiid underneath 27 points per
game
last year it's been a couple days
michael since this
thunder team played great action high
law what a dish there from chris paul
well they know that
gallo can you know score with the
basketball so he's going to attract good
defense
to live with that kind of possession
right where it needs to be it's like
they knew they were going to do it the
entire time
the thunder did shave off 10 points from
the deepest deficit
still plenty of time and there's a good
start to open up
this third quarter as sga takes the bump
captain the foul on the scoop
the thunder defense has been so sound
as sga responds with the deep three you
can kind of see him
[Applause]
excellent give-and-go dish adams again
and gilda's alexander maybe gets
unleashed on that slam
and sonic what a night for him huh yeah
come to get the lead
builders alexander navigates beautifully
scores and draws
a hat from land oh was that sweet to
back
misses once again you get in that
painted area where you've been very
deserved to get a stop on that play just
good team defense
the stutter step by sga wanted to dump
it off to noel still plenty of times he
hoping man
48 minutes and now ingles
miss communication with gobert sga turns
on the speed down the lane
and that'll count it that turnover the
eagles just do it
right to the blue jersey well you just
make them see a crowd and you got the
right guy trying to make a decision
with the basketball in ingles and shay
you know patience here hopefully will
pay off as you continue
to set the jazz up you get him standing
flat-footed
very pleased with the overall decision
as
sga counted in the foul inside
noel knocked it free momentarily from
mitchell contest
another offensive rebound by gobert it's
free and uh nader sends it up to gilgis
alexander he's free and he slams it home
in transition
sj checks the clock it's at five wants
to make a move
on grant got to the rim and it pointed
pinballed right in
five on the timer for jojo's alexander
long strides got to the rim
and somehow that off-balance left-handed
floater
schroeder trying to turn the corner
outside
sga is gonna have to make a move stop
from the baseline and floats it up and
in
and it poked away now adam's outside
nader tees it up that three is good
with 2.4 seconds and then a turnover
sga got it up is it good and he banked
it in
at the buzzer and right now it should
count seconds thanks to this
sga at the buzzer i know he didn't you
know that's good pressure by
first that time just just put enough on
him and that'll be an and one
for shea gill just alexander smooth just
enough of a hesitation there
and that's tough to do it i know i'm
going to give it to someone else
see if we can get something out of this
place sj what a hard drive
somehow muscled it up over a kobo
see if the thunder go two for one here
[Applause]
sga step back three just the second
three-point attempt to the night
and that one splashes on
gilda's alexander gorgeous ball fake and
spin for the deuce
leads them in scoring tonight is cashed
in both under successes
is your one shot yeah xavier mcdaniels
taught me that one
sga all kinds of contactors are gonna
count it will
good defensive plays here in this third
quarter that's why it's just a one
possession game
well sga found his stroke at the line
had some layups now he steps outside and
drains the three well they put everybody
on it patty mills
lamarcus aldridge's tamar derozan just
continues to give you the same thing
that ball is coming through the bottom
of that net
this team they just feel his confidence
out on the floor and players have told
me that
when he starts knocking down shots they
start to say uh-oh
want to get it up the floor quickly
sga will drive on dellavedova and count
the
bucket and the foul now sga with an
opportunity for the old-fashioned
three-point play and the thunder on a
7-0 run
just terrific action by sga you hear the
whistle young player with watson you
heard the whistle right there boom
he just keeps going you never know i'm a
big movie bub
are you happy about the new star wars
what a great action there high low and a
beautiful cut and finish by
sga to the rinse three-point make
thompson's hook shot no good sga
one-on-one with garland
using the long strides got up there
counted in the foul as he somehow
got it up over the rim and it spun home
he's been a completely different shooter
over the last couple of games factor
sga goes right at cool roots counted in
the foul
defense watch this good defense but see
that left hand come out that's what got
him casually
sends it up the floor to sga
sj oh what a finish with that left hand
boy terrance ferguson had some massive
ambitions
this is sga as he will quiet things down
with that slam
paul with the step extra pass
give us alexander wide open strokes it
and that's the buzzer he sticks it
changes
to close the half he talked about the
thunder had been shooting a pretty
decent clip this whole first half how
about that
ball movement that ball was like a hot
potato
from the start you got to remember this
started from 10 seconds all the way back
on the other end of the floor
there's 0-0 with the latest i thought
that was a tough shot
hand in his face as well another tough
drive and the bank and
counted in this game just wasn't able to
finish but does here
well he he caught him lenny
and the thunder come up with the
turnover and that's what you got to do
you got to make him see a crowd nice
drive and it's going to count what a
move
sga took the bump and sub out banked it
in
[Applause]
boston
[Applause]
how about this stripping the ball was
dennis schroeder
well you're right some great defensive
plays on hart
he's
alexander from the wing thunder again
get a little extension on the lead and
how about baseley
step for step with the seven footer
thunder in transition sga right down the
lane goes right by collins and spins it
home
beat at every point too absolutely
some gas in that tank but defend that
three-point shot
which has been to your advantage wow
look at this
three-pointer just as i'm talking about
defending
well the difference is they've missed
23s they're seven of 27.
oh my goodness what a drive that's ga
just lows the defense and
i like this play he went all the way to
the basket got the exchange
got a head and took the contact in the
hit there by heel
now noelle steps right into the passing
lane knocks it free
lobs it up sga oh what a play
with one hand redirected it off the
glass
mr henson henson again trying to front
the post to prevent any kind of entry
pass
sga hard drive down low and scores as he
backs it in
love good play as well as jay will
quickly back down the floor with the
reverse layer because he spins that one
home
basically you know who's had some
starting you know time
in the last uh month of the season
that's a great move here once again by
no one home in the last 30 games of the
season folks
where a hail mary and it goes in
on the 13-3 run they're trying to answer
back and sga is going to have an
opportunity
very old-fashioned three-point play
should go this alexander
signing what to do here in transition
we'll take the bump that's gonna count
on the foul
plays the continuation you know what i'm
gonna say this is nasty come on man this
is an old school
i'm talking like finger rolling
basketball that you don't know what he's
going to do
behind the arc that was one of your keys
coming in defending the three-point shot
sga boy stops pops ahead and it's nice
move
good defense not allow him to get a
clean look sga steps into it from three
and knocks it down and that's a big shot
since the first quarter down to four
sga trying to get it a little closer and
he does with another three
did a good job of flipping the script
though in that painted area
oh how about that steel right by shea
well he just picked the
concrete
[Applause]
sga hard drive takes the bump spins it
home and the foul
sga back in now trying to size up the
beam
he wants the three and how about sga
splashes that one home from behind the
arc
sga getting harassed out of the
perimeter
but you still like those two quick fouls
though not even a minute off the clock
for the lead sga the high kiss off the
glass
how about sga making a tough shot off
the glass to put the thunder ahead as
you said what since the first quarter
was it that the thunder actually had a
lead in this ball game
team knocked away sga keeps the
possession alive it's under five
has to drive steps back tough shot on
the way and he's got to go
did not panic timer sga has to make a
move
sizing up snell steps back tough shot
and he knocks it down
shea gil just alexander no panic no
problem
we see both teams exchanging buckets
tough shot